so you know my bit about like it's gonna
be 30. I'm not [__] 30. when I when I
play Counter-Strike oh yeah
so
there's a badge on your account and it's
a it's a coin it's a 10-year coin
that means you've had the game for 10
years okay and I'm playing with these
guys and they kind of sound older
and then one of them goes man we all got
that 10-year coin you know we're [__]
old
I started laughing and I go holy [__] I
don't even notice that one of them goes
bro how old are you I go well 34. and he
goes I'm 35.
and then another dude starts laughing
he's like yeah you know I'm one of
them's like [__] I'm close like you
didn't he didn't want to like admit to
being close to 30. uh and then one guy
on our team goes
man I'm 37. he sounds like Stevo
and it was this super surreal moment
where I think all of us went damn
because like one guy this is right after
you've reinstalled too yeah yeah right
yeah yeah one guy's playing and or he's
like making a call out and his kid is
just screaming in the background not
like crying just like the kids playing
and I'm just laughing because we're all
then making these jokes about
[__] that we remember from the game way
back okay and it was this kind of just
surreal thing where we go bro we can all
remember right now you guys are like
veterans yeah yeah
well that's where you know that's where
my tinnitus comes from yeah exactly yeah
all those grenades and [__] yeah
um but it was like a weird thing where I
think all of us were in that moment
thinking [__]
we can remember when we were 17.
like screaming outside then I had
another game where it was like four of
us had the 10-year coins
and then there's one really young kid
raging like he
he almost clutch Aces like he almost
kills all five players and then he dies
and he's like I wish I could do his
voice perfect when he goes what the [__]
where the [__] did my bullets go I'm
shooting him right in the [__] face
and we're all laughing we're like bro
it's fine
like how old are you man he's like I'm
20.
it's like relax yeah you got a whole
life ahead of you yeah and he he's like
[__] angry and then he's like I mean
it's just a piece of [__] game and I
said bro relax look at that coin brother
I've been dealing with this [__] for
over 10 years oh dude I go it doesn't
get any better I said the oldest lamest
[__] I said man you gotta learn how to
be chill because if you're mad about
this wait till you call Triple A once
and then like giving them life advice
yeah yeah and then all the other guys
are like son yeah yeah
so the guy goes oh bro wait till wait
till your internet gets [__] up in
your new apartment oh dude you're not
even yeah yeah just call Verizon one
[__] time he's like just wait call
Spectrum yeah yeah yeah I don't know it
was just so you know it definitely felt
like
you know I was out there with the with
the guys at the Legion Hall you guys
need a new coin for how long you stay
clean yeah that's what you need yeah
I think they'll
nah the relapses would just be yeah you
never then you need a new coin for how
often you relapse yeah
it never goes away have you seen Luke
can you pull up Conor McGregor's most
recent Instagram post he just put this
up an hour ago yeah I was watching it on
my car and in my car while I was driving
oh well yeah
you're gonna love this
okay I better because if I don't no no
that's dependency go to the fourth one
that's his Mo oh wait wait go back down
one the second one where he's looking
into the camera
one right underneath that nope yep
this dude is always showing [__] man
that's good it's just always so in
Cochran
like that bro
how would you describe this for the uh
for the audio listeners
um I would describe man all right how'd
I describe this okay picture Conor
McGregor right
now picture being forehead to forehead
is Conor McGregor
and he's got a big old smile okay
picture him like almost cradling you a
little bit in his arms oh you think he's
holding it's almost like he's holding
you like a baby okay and uh but he's
also on an exercise bike yeah yeah he's
shirtless he's pantsless
um and I think those could be boxer
briefs or just straight up underwear I
don't know
and uh he's pedaling showing [__]
that's how I describe it this does look
like a gray workout though
dude in like oh [__] Versace
whities yeah doing an exercise bike on a
yacht bro the the post before
God fearing man
go to the next one
or no
the next one that one
these were like three in a row like
within hours of each other yeah
laughs
[Music]
ah
I see what he's doing oh so has he done
this before board yeah he's on that part
of the family vacation where you're like
[__] I'm bored yeah
I want to go home yeah anyways I thought
you'd enjoy that oh yeah no I appreciate
that man yeah no problem I saw it and
the first thing I thought was Noel would
love this oh dude look at this athlete
showing [__]
that really is uh yeah yeah he's he's
lonely out there yeah
there's literally no one around him to
go bro
relax yeah
what are you training for
you you're not fighting this here
there's no fight this year
what's what's going on
so was he gonna fight and then
he was supposed to want to do the drug
test in December yeah and then there was
something with the window of time for
test right and then he didn't do it
right
or he wasn't able to right but he's
definitely on steroids right no
yes no no no no no come on
not Connor yeah he would never do that
yeah
it's just you know the face of his or
this the shape of his face just changed
yeah that happens sometimes he's eating
good yeah he's a fat man yeah
how about that trunk mug which one the
mug shot oh yeah I think it's good
yeah
like it's all things considered it's
like a good mug shot it's a good meme
yeah it's [__] he nailed it I just
like his he mailed it
like that's good
it's so good the angles on his eyes are
crazy man
yeah he looks like the rock nah man
I mean yes yes sorry yes but I just mean
the angle of his eyes
like they're I love the height and the
weight yeah so good oh it wasn't self
six two two hundred and fifteen pounds I
think or six three solid but can you
look it up because I don't want to miss
quote because it's funny
because there's just no way it's true
and then it's like he's self-reported to
save time
oh interesting yeah so are you saying
shorter
I think he's I think he's heavier than
that probably oh he's he's Hefty oh you
think he's thick
six foot three two fifteen like that's
pretty pretty lean that would be pretty
lean right there pretty felt I feel like
you have to be kind of built for that
yeah
true what true yeah or maybe you know we
don't know big guy wait we shouldn't
speak so confidently what does it say
Trump's booking record declared the
former president's height to be six foot
three and his way 250 pounds 215 nearly
30 pounds lighter than his disclosed
weight at the time of his last Official
White House physical
he's been he's been cotton man yeah yeah
he was bulking back that nice cutting
yeah he's on the down yeah he's getting
ready for the stage sorry I'm still
chuckling at us confidently speaking on
what it means actually I have no [__]
idea we have no idea
I just added I was like what is it you
know whatever that is like four or five
inches taller than me just add times
that by 10 pounds an inch yeah you know
we don't know what it's like up there
yeah
we're down here with the rest of us yeah
hovering hovering hovering around the
160.